we can't go into it thinking you know
what if i get hurt uh
i feel like that'll just hold you back
and for me
for me personally i know it you know the
nfl is a different beast
but i if you've watched me play before
if you know me you know i try to stay as
safe as possible obviously i'm not the
biggest stature you know but
uh you know hits are inevitable
kyle murray with us last week at the
super bowl in atlanta not a big guy not
tall not thick i i
slight and i don't know where you could
put extra extra meat on those bones it's
just not the frame that you would expect
to get big enough to really help him
withstand the pounding of playing in the
nfl but big cat he's going to the
scouting combine i i think my gut tells
me
that they're trying to create the
impression he's all in with football
even if he may not be all in with
football but he knows that he has to
come off as being all in with football
to get drafted as high as possible he
sees where he gets drafted and then he
makes a decision the final decision
between football and baseball i think i
think he's going to try to keep a foot
in both boats for as long as he possibly
can even though he's not going to admit
that
so you think that he will get drafted
and then could still potentially go to
baseball basically the team who drafts
him wasting a draft pick on him yes yes
oh i think that no i i thought because i
have yet to get the impression that he
is truly and completely all in with
football and he's going to have to
convince those scouts and he's gonna
have to do it at the scouting combine
and you know there were some awkward
moments last week when he was on dan
patrick's show i mean he gets into that
meeting room when they do the 15-minute
speed dating with these guys
he he had better be clear that he's all
in with football and you know you got to
pay back the money to the a's you got to
renounce all you can with the a's i
don't know how you completely burn that
bridge and convince people it's burned
but i mean if he gets drafted in let's
say he doesn't get drafted in the first
round
let's say he 32 teams pass on him he
gets drafted by a team in round two what
does he do at that point i i think that
there is a certain level below which he
gets drafted maybe a certain team or two
or three he gets drafted by and he says
screw it i'm going back to oakland
okay so
he's definitely getting drafted in the
first round and i'm saying that not
because he's a first round grade or the
you know he has the prototypical nfl
size anything that you know a normal
first rounder would be
he's getting drafted in the first round
because he's electric it's a copycat
league
no one wants to pass on kyler murray and
watch kylie murray you know it mike
you've been covering the nfl forever
teams want to win but they also want to
not be embarrassed and they don't want
to pass on a guy who everyone says
that's the heisman trophy winner that's
a guy who will fit perfectly with the
new offensive system so he's getting
drafted in the first round and i like
it just it's going to happen whether
he's going to be great i have no idea
but he's going to get drafted the first
round because you know how the combine
works you know how the draft works this
is the time of year where we sit and we
talk up every single quarterback and you
get every single quarterback going from
oh well maybe second third round to the
first round and every team talks
themselves into dwayne haskins and will
greer and kyler murray and uh trace
mcsorley all these guys are going to get
drafted high because the quarterback
position still rules the nfl and teams
are deathly deathly afraid of passing on
the next big thing
well and and i don't disagree with that
because last year five guys taking in
round one they all became starters by
the end of the season so that that whole
that copycat notion that we see from
time to time if anything it is going to
cause quarterbacks to get overdrafted
this year and and i think the tension
will be between the scouts who will look
at kyler murray and say this is not
going to work this is not going to
happen this guy is not nearly big enough
strong enough thick enough to thrive at
the nfl level but then you're gonna have
a jimmy haslem who waltzes into the room
and and you know
says hey uh this is what we're doing i
own the team and owners get involved all
the time and make these picks and
influence these picks you don't have to
make the pick it's one of the privileges
of being a billionaire it's very easy to
influence what the people who work for
you do you don't have to say much you
don't have to drop a lot of hints to get
them to understand what you want but i
think that's what happens now we gotta
look at the teams that need quarterbacks
but the teams that need quarterbacks or
the teams that have older quarterbacks
and they want to get on this bandwagon
of having a young guy who's going to be
around for the next 10 or 15 years those
are the hot spots i don't disagree with
that but i still think big cat there's
there's a spot maybe in round you know
it's if he's not a top 10 top 12 top 15
pick
i i
i think he's going to reserve the right
deep down he's never going to say it but
i think deep down there's still that
chance to go back to baseball if he's
not thrilled with how the draft plays
out for him personally well of course
there's always a chance that he could go
back to baseball because that like when
you're thinking about kylo murray and
his decision of what to do you can't go
play baseball and and then say it's not
working out i can't hit a curveball i'm
gonna go play football you can play
football and then do the tim tebow and
later in your life say i'm gonna go try
baseball it probably won't work out
because he needs years and years of uh
you know hitting and batting practice
and being in the minors
but
this is the only pat you know football
to baseball is the only way it works not
baseball to football the only thing i
would throw out there to you is i think
him going to the combine shows that he
is committed to football because he's
not going to spring training i don't
know the exact date for oakland a's
spring training but if he was committed
to baseball he would right now right
this second be saying i need to do
everything i can i need to i need to
face pitchers every single day i need to
get as many reps as i can because it's
such an uphill battle to get to the
major leagues in baseball and he's
already not doing that because i would
assume for the next month he or three
weeks he will be training for the
combine not hitting you know 95 mile an
hour fastballs
here's what i think is going on though
and our spring training report dates
february 15. i think the a's have been
deliberately
cooperative with kyler murray and
they've been over backwards to
accommodate him
thinking that
maybe if that that relationship is still
in existence if people feel if scouts if
if owners if coaches feel like there's
still something there that he could
pivot and go back to maybe there will be
a hesitation to make him a first round
pick i just look the the guy that was
trying to sell whatever he was trying to
sell last week whatever he was trying to
explain i thought he was okay on our
show on dan's show it was it was it was
so awkward if that's the guy that shows
up for these interviews you may scare
away some of these teams and and
ultimately the coach may go to the owner
and say i know you want this guy but i
can't guarantee you he's going to sign a
contract he may go right back to
baseball i think part of what the a's
are doing they are playing it this way
to try to kind of subtly scare off the
nfl by causing them to think that kyler
murray very well may say hey you know
what the a's have been great to me i'm
just going to go play baseball i think
we have to treat that as a serious
possible outcome
you're right on all that the one thing
i'll give him a slight pass for is i
don't know how many college kids can go
from norman oklahoma to the super bowl
to having to be interviewed by the likes
of dan patrick and mike florio titans of
the industry yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports